how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and everything relating to the
mcu
and today is a great day because we have
some spider-man
3 news right now spider-man 3 is kind of
a mystery marvel studios hasn't really
told us much and tom holland hasn't
spoiled anything yet
it was recently announced that
spider-man 3 did get pushed back
a month from november to december now
having a christmas
release date which will in fact help the
movie make at least a billion dollars
but
we don't really know too much about the
film as far as the plot is concerned and
who's going to be in it there's plenty
of speculation over the sinister six
there's speculation over
craven the hunter and of course
everybody would just
love for venom to appear in spider-man 3
as well
but we really don't know the plot we
just know that spider-man is going to be
on the run
but today we have a little bit of news
as an actor has been confirmed to be
returning to spider-man 3 and we'll talk
about it in this video but first if
you're new
be sure to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the mcu news and so you
can enter my giveaway for a chance to
win a scarlet witch
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe like the video leave a comment
down below and i'm picking a winner on
monday
so right now as it stands very few
characters have been confirmed to be
returning to spider-man 3. we know that
tom holland of course is returning as
peter parker and jay jonah jameson has
spoke recently about his return as well
and then of course zendaya will be
returning as
mj but besides that not much is really
known but today in an exclusive report
from
deadline.com they have revealed that
tony revolori who plays
flash thompson in spider-man homecoming
and spider-man far from home will be
returning for
the third film now flash has had a
pretty interesting story arc and
spider-man homecoming and then and far
from home and it's going to be even more
interesting in spider-man 3.
of course he was peter parker's bully in
homecoming and kind of in far from home
as well
but in far from home we saw him get an
admiration for
spider-man and now he knows that peter
parker is spider-man peter parker the
kid that he used to pick on
is his idol so we know that peter parker
is going to be on the run
in spider-man 3 and perhaps flash is
even going to be willing to help him
in the movie as well perhaps flash will
even come to respect peter parker for
being spider-man and actually want to
help him and
end up helping him now something pretty
interesting to note about flash thompson
that some people may not know is that in
the comics he actually goes on to become
agent venom in the comics flash and
peter actually have a pretty good
developing story arc
they start off just as we see them in
spider-man homecoming and far from home
flash picks on peter
ruthlessly but over time he actually
finds out that he is spider-man and he
begins to respect him and the two of
them
actually become very close flash would
then go on to join the army after
college
and unfortunately he would end up losing
both of his legs in war
but he would kind of get his legs back
by bonding with the venom
symbiote then he would go on to become
agent venom
one of the only characters to go on and
use the venom symbiote to do
good and actually use the symbiote to
fight evil
agent venom works for the us military
and is one of the coolest versions of
venom that we see in the comics but as
far as flash thompson goes in the mcu
it's kind of different
in the comics flash is a big jock who's
a star in the high school football team
and we don't exactly see that with flash
thompson in the mcu
but that doesn't mean that marvel
wouldn't take the opportunity to
at least briefly bond him with the venom
symbiote at some point in time and
seeing as how flash is basically in love
with spider-man and could take the
opportunity of
becoming like him by bonding with the
symbiote it is something that we could
briefly see in the mcu
now it's not something that they would
take from tom hardy but we know that
there are other symbiotes out there
and now that the venom verse with sony
is kind of bonding with the mcu
anything is pretty much possible at this
point in time because flash thompson is
being brought back for a pretty specific
purpose
whether that's just simply to be a
friend to peter parker or whether or not
he's going to end up helping spider-man
and peter in some way shape or form
we'll have to wait and see but in the
meantime this does reveal that at some
point in time he will be in contact with
his friends whether that's in the
beginning
in the middle to ask for some help or at
the end he finally clears his name and
is able to go back to living a normal
life and hang out with his friends
if marvel is playing nice with sony
right now it would be a missed
opportunity to not have agent venom at
least make a tiny cameo at some point in
time
in the mcu and with flash thompson
returning in spider-man 3 it could be
possible but let me know what you think
his role is going to be in spider-man 3.
leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on all the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof